here's what to do with your old Chargers
and
cables our next question is from Manny
on Twitter
SLX what do you do with old Chargers or
cables do you trash them or can they be
recycled by the company I'm hanging on
to them because I can't find a
responsible way to dispose of them uh
yes you're trying to be generous here
and Bravo for that we often fret about
being too stingy in our lives this
hearkens back to the charity question we
were answering earlier no one ever
regrets being too generous and so this
person Manny doesn't just want to throw
away the Chargers I want someone else to
be able to do something with them and if
you can sell them great I whenever I
need a charger the first place I go is
onto eBay and they're usually new or
like new Chargers there and I can buy
them at a radically reduced cost however
if you don't want to hold on to it for a
period of time that it takes to sell and
you just want to get it out of your
house yeah there's some things that you
can do in fact I've got this article
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes over at theminimalists.com
podcast this is from familyhandyman.com
here's what to do with your old Chargers
and cables we'll talk about this
practically and the maybe TK can butt in
with some philosophical insights for us
if you've got a collection of outdated
Chargers cables or wires collecting dust
here's what you can do with them did you
know that electronic waste is the
fastest growing waste stream
globally this is due to both the
shortened lifespan of our electronic
devices and society's demanding for the
newest Hightech products the
Environmental Protection Agency
estimates that only 15 to 20% of e waste
is recycled the rest of these
Electronics go directly into landfills
incinerators or areally exported to
developing countries common practice is
to use an electronic device for while
and discard it once a new model comes
out unfortunately if the new model or
device has a different charging port it
renders your old collection of charging
cables virtually useless so what do you
do when it's time to clean out the
drawer full of old no longer relevant
cables and they give you four options
here I just want to run you through them
shortly first one is a retail drop off I
will often go to Best Buy The Local Best
Buy they have a little kiosk there and
you can even go to best spy.com and you
can see what cables Chargers and things
will accept if you just don't want to
deal with it you don't want to start
asking your friends and family and all
this you don't want to try to sell it
you don't think Goodwill is going to
take this little charger you can take it
to Best Buy or a similar Electronics
retailer and they have the donation
process they will handle those
electronics for you the second thing is
recycle there are a lot of places where
you can actually recycle you may not be
able to throw all the cables and
chargers in your regular recy recycling
bin but here's what the article has to
say about it when removed from the
sheath pure copper wire can be sold for
Salvage it likely won't be worth a
fortune but you can at least make some
cash off old cables that you you're
never going to use again any metal
recycling center will accept your copper
corded wires and will likely accept most
of your small electronics in addition to
other wires and cables you can also sell
or recycle used electronics so the the
thing that I think about here when I
lived in the cabin in the middle of
nowhere we didn't have a trash service
that came picked up our trash I used to
have to drive to a trash jump and I
drove to recycling center and part of
that recycling center was metal and they
you could donate your metal and they
wouldn't pay us there but a lot of
recycling centers actually will pay
people in fact it's why I often see in
West Hollywood people going through all
the trash cans in the mornings before
trash day because they are getting out
the metal so they can go sell it on
their own now it takes a little a little
bit of work but if you're willing to do
the work you can take it to a metal
recycling place and they will do it for
you uh third thing is give it to a
friend or family member you did this
recently I think with an old charger is
that right yeah I took it yeah and it
was perfectly timed because my this was
for my laptop my cable was starting to
fray at the base and the wires were
getting exposed and I went man I'm going
to have to buy a new one and he texted
in the group chat and said hey anybody
need a charger I said me actually please
bring it to the studio
and it was one of those extra ones that
you get sometimes when you buy a new
phone or a new device you know you
already have a charger and and and they
put it in the bag it's like you got to
take it it comes with it whatever and
and so it just kind of goes in a box
because it's new it's nice I don't feel
like selling it right now and I was just
going through some stuff like some of
this has just got to go and uh it worked
out really well thank you TK and I would
say there's one thing that's not on the
list but I have Chargers as long as they
still work with my devices my idea of a
rich life as we talked about with REM
saty is having Chargers in multiple
rooms of my house whether it's a phone
charger computer charger and I have it
in a rather aesthetic presentation I
would drill a hole in my shelf and
there's like a charge stand underneath
and I just have a few cables that come
up throughout the charge stand in my
entry way so you can charge a phone
there or a computer there you can charge
a clock there there are all these
different things that I can charge right
there but then I also have a computer I
don't want to unplug that every time I
want to charge something in a different
room so I have a charger in my office or
I have a charger here at the studio or
I'll have a charger that I have in my
laptop bag when I'm traveling so it's
not wrong or bad to have more than one
charger the question is am I actually
using these things right and if so don't
you don't have to feel compelled to get
rid of it but then when they're out of
date we have these examples for you as
well the final one is donate to a stem
program schools and many nonprofits have
STEM Science technology engineering and
Mathematics programs or projects that
often use use older technology your old
cable cords Chargers and wires very well
may be so outdated uh for may may not be
so outdated that they're good for
educational purposes so it could be that
a local stem program or local school has
a use for them now takes a little leg
work on your part you got to make some
phone calls for that if you don't just
want to go to Best Buy or to your local
metal recycling center do you have any
additional insights
TK the the one thing I'll add is that
responsibility is the best combination
of what is right and what you are
capable of doing within reason and so
what that means is the responsible path
for you might look different than the
responsible path for someone else why is
this important when it comes to getting
rid of things it's easy to fall prey to
the Trap of spending all of your time
researching and researching to make the
perfect decision about the perfect way
to recycle but if you're spending 12
months or 6 months obsessing over the
right way to get rid of something then
you're still allowing that possession to
rob you of your time and your life
energy time and energy that could be
going to family and other meaningful
relationships projects and other things
that are important to you and so set
aside an amount of time that is within
reason for you and say I'll look into
this stuff that he just talked about one
hour one to two hours I'll look into it
and then I know that no decision I ever
make is going to be perfect and Beyond
the capacity for criticism so I'm going
to pick the best thing that seems
reasonable to me based on that hour of
research and then I'm going to move
forward with my life I'm going to get
rid of it in that way and move forward
with my life so as you're thinking about
this in terms of that word you use
responsibility remember it's not just
about what you think is right it's not
about being perfect it's about what's
what's reasonable for you and what
you're talking about there is setting up
a boundary can I sell this within a week
that is a boundary but it also that
boundary forces you to take action now
because I've set a deadline it's a
selling deadline in fact we call call it
the selling deadline rule if you can get
rid of it in a week great if not I lower
the price if it's 30 days I know I can't
sell it I'm not willing to sit on it any
longer I'm going to donate it and then
we gave you a bunch of resources here
that you can take those old cables and
Chargers that you aren't going to use
anymore they're just getting in the way
they're literally tangling up your life
and you can let them go hey I hope you
enjoyed that highlight clip from the
minimalist private podcast if You' like
to see the full maximal episode plus
more be sure to check us out on patreon
the link is in the description patreon
is what helps us keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free if you're not yet
ready for that check out another
[Music]
video